[Música]
crisis social y política en ecuador el
parlamento debate un procedimiento
presentado por la oposición para
destituir al presidente guillermo lasso
en medio de protestas
antigubernamentales de movimientos
indígenas que ya llevan dos semanas en
el mes del orgullo el eje vete este fin
de semana se registraron múltiples
desfiles en todo el mundo para celebrar
al colectivo y seguir exigiendo el
respeto a sus derechos e identidades
organizaciones sociales pierden que
centroamérica es una de las regiones más
atrasadas en derechos para la comunidad
y un hallazgo accidental reveló al mundo
150 cartas inéditas que recibió gabriel
garcía márquez por parte de
personalidades como pablo neruda bill
clinton y fidel castro- entre muchas
otras tendremos un análisis sobre sus
vínculos políticos y activismo
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de france 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias del continente
americano y santiago galicia y
comenzamos en ecuador porque después del
anuncio del fin del estado de excepción
el parlamento comenzó a debatir un
procedimiento presentado por la
oposición para destituir al presidente
guillermo lasso el país recordemos está
sumido en una crisis política y social
muy profunda que se intensificó hace ya
dos semanas cuando comenzaron protestas
indígenas en contra del gobierno gabriel
coll d'en no recuerda los eventos y
jugadores está sacudido por importantes
manifestaciones sociales desde hace casi
dos semanas las más grandes desde 2019
las protestas empezaron el 13 de junio
en las zonas rurales del país convocadas
por la conaie la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador
entre las 10 demandas presentadas al
gobierno están la reducción y
congelación de los precios del
combustible y el control de los precios
de los productos de primera necesidad en
un contexto de inflación creciente y de
pobreza en el país estamos en verdad
literalmente muriendo de hambre no hay
trabajo los productos del campo están
siendo minimizados no hay él
el apoyo correspondiente del gobierno
con el alza de los combustibles pues
automáticamente alzó todos los productos
de primera necesidad el gobierno acusó a
los indígenas de bloquear rutas y
reprimir las manifestaciones llevando a
enfrentamientos violentos entre civiles
y policías
rápidamente los estudiantes y varios
sindicatos se unieron al movimiento
generando protestas masivas en la
capital quitó el 17 de junio el
presidente anunció el inicio del estado
de inscripción me comprometo a defender
nuestra capital y a defender el país
esto me obliga a declarar el estado de
excepción en pichincha imbabura y
cotopaxi a partir de la medianoche de
hoy guillermo la suya muy varias veces
al diálogo pero la con ello denunció la
falta de respuesta concreta del gobierno
realmente es un momento muy complejo
nosotros hubiéramos esperado que el
presidente de la republica responda a
los temas centrales sobre la crisis la
pobreza que está viviendo nuestra gente
sin embargo no lo hemos tenido las dos
enfrenta desde el viernes a un
procedimiento de destitución
sin embargo anunció este sábado el fin
del estado de excepción
las manifestaciones han dejado un saldo
de al menos 5 muertos y decenas de
heridos y las consecuencias del govern
19 continúan sintiéndose en todo el
continente brasil por ejemplo vive un
déficit de medicinas en sus farmacias
aunque expertos y directivos tengan
focalizado el eje fundamental del
conflicto la crisis sea en un momento en
el que se espera un aumento de casos de
dengue y kobe 19 informes de rafael
pérez
desabastecimiento de medicamentos en
brasil los farmacéuticos del gigante
suramericano están en alerta debido a la
falta de insumos médicos la crisis
coincide con la llegada del invierno
austral y el aumento de los casos de
dengue y kobe 19 también así sea
la encuesta que realizamos demostró que
el 98% de los farmacéuticos consultados
reportaron falta de medicación así dos
consultas
demostraron fault y el desabastecimiento
es generalizado no es localizado
con más de 200 millones de habitantes
brasil fabrica alrededor del 70% de los
medicamentos que consume pero importa el
90% de las materias primas necesarias
para producirlas fundamentalmente de
china directivos brasileros ven el
problema a escala mundial
este escenario es global es un problema
que tiene dos causas principales que
serían la guerra en ucrania y el cierre
prolongado de china la entrada no es
suficiente entonces no se puede producir
si en consecuencia no se puede
distribuir distribuir
primeras señales de insuficiencia
llegaron a finales del pasado año tan
solo en sao paulo la ciudad más poblada
de brasil el 98% de los farmacéuticos
paulistas tanto públicos como privados
padecen el desabastecimiento la mayoría
señaló fundamentalmente la falta de
antibióticos y junio es el mes en el que
se conmemora el orgullo lgtb durante
todo este fin de semana se registraron
múltiples desfiles en varios países de
todo el mundo para celebrar al colectivo
y seguir exigiendo el respeto a sus
derechos e identidades aunque los
coloridos desfiles en américa latina'
han sido diferentes en cada ciudad todos
ellos tuvieron algo en común un llamado
por la igualdad de derechos y el fin de
la violencia contra la comunidad
centroamérica es catalogada por
organizaciones sociales como una de las
regiones más atrasadas en cuanto a
derechos de diversidad sexual y de
género el informe de juan pabló lucumí
centroamérica es la región del
continente en donde la comunidad lgbt
más cuenta con menos derechos como
actores civiles en panamá las personas
del mismo sexo no pueden casarse y no
pueden adoptar al no poder establecer su
estado civil como pareja no pueden
realizar una declaración de impuestos
conjunta o acceder a un préstamo de
vivienda como matrimonio es hora de que
la corte suprema de justicia saque de la
gaveta loco y no consultiva de costa
rica y panamá del matrimonio civil
porque todos los ciudadanos tenemos los
mismos derechos
según registros de la oea panamá
introdujo la despenalización de la
homosexualidad tan solo hasta 2008 el
salvador aprobó su primer derecho para
la comunidad en 2010 y costa rica creó
legislaciones a favor del colectivo
apenas hace 8 años atrás en 2014 pues
como avances de los sectores sociales el
grt en américa latina podemos encontrar
realmente una lista muy variable que
cada uno de los países ha ido adoptando
países como colombia el matrimonio
igualitario y la adopción por ejemplo ya
son una realidad pero en lugares como
ecuador o perú siguen siendo discusiones
muy importantes para los sectores
sociales el eje
en nicaragua no existe ninguna ley que
defienda los derechos de diversidad
sexual y en marzo de este año el
congreso de guatemala votó a favor de
una ley que prohíbe el matrimonio
homosexual y eleva la pena de prisión
por aborto según reportes de la
organización sin violencia el fbi entre
2014 y 2020 3500 99 personas fueron
asesinadas por su género en américa
latina y el caribe
y un hecho conmueve a los fanáticos de
la literatura y en particular a los de
gabriel garcía márquez porque al revisar
los archivos fotográficos que dejó cabo
una de sus nietas encontró de manera
accidental una caja que contenía 150
cartas inéditas que recibió el escritor
colombiano por parte del poeta chileno
pablo neruda el ex presidente de eeuu
bill clinton el líder cubano fidel
castro y el actor robert redford entre
muchos otros y en france 24 dialoga mos
con álvaro santana acuña comisario de la
exposición gabriel garcía márquez la
creación de un escritor global en el
museo de arte moderno de méxico y esto
nos decía sobre su vínculo con la
política y su activismo
sí sin duda de hecho una de las cosas
que se exploran en esta exposición en la
casa de garcía márquez y también de
manera más amplia en la exposición de la
que yo soy comisario en este momento en
el museo de arte moderno de méxico es el
de poder mostrar que garcía márquez tras
publicarse años en soledad se convirtió
no solamente en un escritor muy famoso
cada uno de sus libros vendía en
millones de ejemplares sino también que
se convirtió en un importante activista
en favor de causas políticas y
culturales de américa latina' y tanto en
esta exposición como la que está en el
museo de arte moderno podemos ver como
garcía márquez pues se interesaba para
solucionar problemas como el
narcotráfico la violencia incluso
también interceder por prisioneros
políticos en diferentes países aunque
también es cierto que muchas de estas
actividades políticas de garcía márquez
pues las realizaba a través del teléfono
entonces estas cartas son una pequeña
muestra
es activismo que garcía márquez realizó
sobre todo en persona y también por
teléfono y finalizamos en mexico y mucha
atención para los fanáticos del modelo
beetle de volkswagen porque prox
aproximadamente 1000 de estos
automóviles recorrieron las calles de
ciudad de méxico este domingo se trató
de la edición número 13 del desfile
anual del beatle y es que el dicho 8
como se apodó a este modelo ya es todo
un clásico que genera fanatismo a lo
largo de todo el mundo
es todo por el momento regresamos en
breve con muchas más noticias continúen
en france 24 y también por supuesto en
france 24 punto com
[Música]